[Music]
the northwest community coming together
to help a teenage worker who had his
bike stolen from a pizzeria it was all
caught on camera
a facebook post to get him a new bike
has more than 1100 shares
surveillance video and above the crust
pizzeria which you can see here
shows a woman cutting the lock and
stealing an employee's bicycle now this
happened on
sunday while jt a 16 year old in foster
care was working
inside to replace the bike they set up a
donation jar they created a
venmo account and since then people have
donated nearly one thousand dollars
it did blow up throughout the community
nothing like what we expected
people were commenting that they want to
donate their bicycles people don't know
what other people go through
and someone like jt who that happened to
him
he's had nothing but negative in his
life but now some good news here's a
look at that video again
this woman stealing his bicycle now to
pay it forward the pizzeria and jt will
be hosting a bicycle drive on saturday
from 1 to 4 in the afternoon
donations will go to the organization
that's the vehicle where it was last
spotted
folks eagle quest nevada those donations
will go there for other
at-risk kids in foster care